Well as,
um,
what we'll do this morning is to start right now and we'll be dealing today with
an the beginnings of our first major epidemic and the course we'll be talking
about bubonic plague this time we'll have an overview of boob [inaudible] plague
and its passage through Western society.
And then the next two classes we'll look at specific features of Boob,
onic plug next time a community responses to the plight and the time after that,
the impact on society and in particular on European culture.
So that's where we're headed.
And this morning we'll have a sort of overview.
No,
one of the reasons for dealing first with the flag is that it's very important
as part of testing the theme of our course,
the theme being one of the themes that epidemic diseases aren't just
interchangeable causes of illness and death,
that each one has its own particular history that's determined by a number of
variables that we'll be looking at,
such as variance the nature of the symptoms of the disease and a number of
others.
And we'll be testing the theory to that.
Epidemic Diseases are major determinants of historical change.
And have major impacts on society will plug in a sense set the standard by which
all other epidemics are judged.
The Plagge was,
we might call it the worst case scenario and we'll see that in later centuries
when society's experienced some new and unfamiliar disease,
they waited anxiously to see if those diseases would be similar in their impact
and especially terrible diseases like cholera and the 19th century and influenza
just after the first world war were said to be the return of the plague.
Tuberculosis,
the great pillar of the 19th century was known also as the white plague.
Now,
what were some of the distinctive features of bubonic plague?
Uh,
first thing stands out is it's extreme virulence.
Now that's one of the first words that we may want to define as we move on.
By that,
I mean it's capacity to cause harm and symptoms and the human body.
It's a measurement of the ability of a pathogen to cause disease we'll plug and
not was highly very alert.
It also struck rapidly.
It caused excruciating and degrading symptoms and it achieved a case fatality
rate.
Another technical term,
which simply means the kill rate that a disease achieved and the case of
bluebonnet plague at normally killed 50 to 70% of the patients that infected
arrayed attained by few other diseases.
It's course in the human body was also terrifyingly swift.
Normally it killed within about three days of the first appearance of symptoms.
Another feature that was characteristic of Boob OnDeck plague was the profile of
its victims.
I mean not both in terms of their age and their social class.
Familiar and DEMEC childhood diseases in a society tend to strike primarily
children and the elderly that if you like,
would be the normal experience of society with infectious diseases.
But the plague was different.
It struck men and women in the prime of life and this fact among others made
plagues seem like an unnatural or might we say supernatural event.
It also magnified the economic and social dislocations that cause.
In other words,
Plagge left and it's wig vast numbers of orphans,
widows and destitute families.
Furthermore,
the plague,
unlike most epidemic diseases,
did not show a predilection for the poor.
It struck universally,
again magnifying the sense that this was the final day of reckoning,
a divine visitation.
Another feature of plague we'll be looking at is terror as a response to it.
All of the things that we'll be saying about plague magnified the responses of
the societies that were afflicted.
Plague was associated with mass hysteria with terror,
with violence,
with religious revivals.
As people sought to assuage the divine wrath was associated with scapegoating
and witch hunts for the guilty people in society responsible for the disaster.
Perhaps those were the sinful,
for those who saw the disease as divine retribution or it could be for a search
for the homicidal agents of some human conspiracy for the demonic interpretation
of disease.
Those might be foreigners,
witches,
Jews,
or poisoners.
Then the plague was important because it generated a major societal response.
The development of the first forms of public health
in part because of its very,
very painless.
The plague inspired the first and most extreme form of public health policy to
protect populations and contain the spread of this trendous and terrible
disease,
plague public health.
And we'll see this more next time.
Involved a military style policy carried out by the army and the navy.
It involved maritime and land based quarantines sanitary coordinance,
which are military.
I lines isolating a population.
It gave rise to past houses or lots to ref toes and to new health authorities
variously called over the centuries health magistrates or boards of health
equipped with extraordinary powers to enforce the plague measures.
And some places there were erected stocks and scaffolds to remind the population
of the powers of these authorities.
Okay.
No early Italian states at the time of the renaissance devoted a special role
deserve,
does special role as the inventors of these public health measures.
This was thrust upon them by their vulnerable position at the geographic center
of trade routes in the Mediterranean.
So we'll see that decisive role in the development of these measures was played
by places like Florence and the great port cities like Genoa,
Naples,
Venice,
okay.
Later centuries we'll see another pattern.
When a new mysterious and frightful disease strikes say cholera,
yellow fever or aids.
One of the first responses of authorities is to return to play egg measures of
self defense.
It's set of generals that they always try to fight the last war over again,
often confronting new enemies with inappropriate strategies.
The same might be sad of public health authorities over the centuries and this
temptation is all the greater for authorities because the battery of anti plague
defenses gives an impression of taking forceful and decisive action providing
the population.
In other words with some sense of security.
A third feature of the plague is it's enormous impact on society.
As we've said,
infectious are not narrow specialized interests.
There are often part of the big picture as essential for understanding a society
in its history as studying war,
religion,
economics,
high politics and culture and not trying to make a case for disease determinism
and I'm not what you might want to call a microbial Marxist.
My argument instead,
it's simply that certain diseases do have a transforming effect on society.
Plague being one of them.
Certain others do not even great killers such as polio or influence them.
We're going to examine why this major difference,
why some diseases have a much more lasting footprint than others,
but bubonic plague was a disease that affected every aspect of society.
It transformed the demography of Europe,
recurring cycles of plague with an epidemic.
Every generation constituted a major break on population between the 14th
century and the 18th it had a devastating effect on economic life and economic
growth.
It also had a major impact on religion and popular culture.
It gave rise to a new piety to cults of plagues,
Saints to passion.
Place plague leapt to an outpouring of sermons and religious pamphlets with a
central theme being what we might call theodicy.
That is how do you justify God's ways towards men adjust and loving God could be
angry and punish sinners who turned from him and disobeyed.
But how were priests and ministers to explain the gruesome suffering and death
of innocence and in particular of children?
So thus also we see another undertow.
We talked about piety.
I would argue that plague also led sometimes to its opposite the terrifying
conclusion,
but how could there be a good god?
Because a loving and all powerful being would not take the lives of half the
population of a great city indiscriminately killing men,
women and children.
So for some the result wasn't an active atheism,
but in mute despair that was not articulated a psychological impact that with
historical hindsight,
we might even call post traumatic stress.
So plague how to major psychological impact on the relationship of human beings
to their mortality and to their God.
Plague had a major impact on the arts and culture and literature we'll be
seeing.
And in fact,
you're starting to see,
I hope already by reading defoe that there's a whole genre of plague literature,
including not only defoe but names like Boccaccio commune Manzoni of whom more
later it affected European painting profoundly.
And we'll be looking at that.
It affected architecture with large numbers of churches dedicated to the
redeemer and the plague.
Saints,
it led to sculpture and plague columns appeared throughout Vianna and the
Austrian cities.
We have our,
even in modern times,
the film that I hope you'll be seeing,
the seventh seal by Bergman plague also had a major impact intellectually on the
medical paradigm of disease.
Plague profoundly tested the humeral framework of disease.
And we can see this in a man I mentioned in the last lecture,
Jude,
all of them are Frauca steroidal,
who developed a theory of contagion aneurysm.
Now the humeral idea,
and Hippocrates had recognized the difficulty that epidemics pose for humoral
theory.
How is it possible to account for vast numbers of people experiencing the same
humeral imbalance at precisely the same time?
Well.
Frauca Storto took that idea and he eliminated the mediation of the humors
suggesting and said that the disease was caused by a poisonous chemical
transmitted in a way he didn't understand from one person to another,
but less let's not think of Frauca Storto as a modern medical scientist.
He thought that plug was caused not by a living entity but by a chemical.
Well,
that's the background.
Then let's remember the history of three pandemics of Gubernick Plagge that
afflicted the west.
Now first,
maybe we should define what we mean an outbreak at what's talk about three terms
and outbreaks and epidemic and a pandemic and outbreak is a small surge in
morbidity and mortality in a locality,
so we might talk of an outbreak of influenza in new haven.
An epidemic is a much bigger surge over a larger area and depend on that is when
an epidemic goes transnational becomes an international phenomenon affecting
pull continents or occasionally going global.
Now the plague struck the west in three pandemic waves.
We'll be talking about the history then of three pandemics of bubonic plague and
each pandemic as a subset if we like,
had a series of recurring visitations that might even last for centuries and in
addition to being cyclical and nonsense plague,
how to pronounce seasonality,
an epidemic of bubonic plague usually began in the spring or summer months and
faded away with the coming of winter,
especially favorable.
We're months that were both hot and wet.
The explanation for that is we'll see,
wasn't a humoral one,
but that provides an ideal environment for fleas which are decisive in plague
and their need for warmth and humidity for their eggs to hatch and they become
inactive and called or very dry climate.
The first pandemic one was that that lasted for two centuries after five 41 a d
and it's called the plague of Justinian.
It was the first appearance of bluebonnet plague as a major player in world
history and there are estimates that it flooded Africa,
Asia,
and Europe with people are guessing,
but there are figures bandied about of perhaps 100 million victims.
There are fewer accounts or records that are survivors.
And there's some debate about whether this so called plague of Justinian was
even bubonic plague at all,
or whether it was some other disease.
But as we speak,
Paleo pathologists or work exhuming bodies from ancient cemeteries in order to
find conclusive DNA evidence to support affirmed diagnosis.
And the latest news is that they're pretty certain that it was bubonic plague.
The second pandemic occurred from the 1330s in the Middle East until the 1830s.
So we have what's thought,
um,
five centuries of bubonic plague.
In the second pandemic,
it began with what was called the black death.
This erupted in Central Asia and the 1330s and first invaded Europe in 1347 and
the early years from 1347 into the 1350s,
we're usually called the black death,
which referred to the first wave of the second pandemic after which it's usually
referred to simply as boop,
onic,
plague,
plague or pestilence.
It may well,
and this is the common theory,
have arrived to board agenda.
We smirch didn't ship that sailed from the Black Sea and the summer of 1347 in
any case,
Italy was the first land to be invaded by the disease.
Again,
as I say,
not by chance because Italy was at the center of the trade routes of the
Mediterranean and therefore it was always at this time permanently at risk.
About a third of the population of Europe is estimated to have perished and
after the 1350s after the black death,
the plague returned more or less once in a generation for a number of centuries
with some famous local epidemics.
Let me just remember some of the worst cases,
Florence and 1348 when the disease killed half the population and that's
portrayed vividly in Bo conscious to Cameron 15 seven 76 to seven belong 1630
again Milan and there are two major plague works of literature,
Monzo novel,
the patrol and his work,
the column of Infamy,
1656 in Naples and 1665 and six in London,
which are reading about into foes journal of the plague here.
Then for reasons we're going to return to the plague was vanquished in western
Europe between the end of the 17th century and the middle of the 18 the last
outbreaks in western Europe of the second pandemic,
we're 1720 to 22 at Marsanne France,
the last on the western [inaudible] PN mainland,
and in 1743 at Messina and Sicily.
Interestingly,
Messina is a convenient and bookend the very first place in western Europe to be
afflicted by the plague and also the last during the second pandemic.
Now don't make the mistake of assuming that the very elements of the plague
declines over the centuries in many cases,
the last step epidemics of the 17th or 18th century where the most devastating
at all of all,
including the experience of London that you're reading about.
Then we come to the third pandemic,
which lasted from about 1855 until 1959 more or less when it fades away,
it began in earnest and attracted world attention in China when an Attoc Hong
Kong and concern in 1894 and as I said,
it lasted until the middle of the 20th century.
Now this pandemic ravaged India and effected five countries,
but mostly not the industrial west.
Apart from a brief flareup in April in Naples and 1899 and an also limited
outbreak in San Francisco in the early years of the 20th century.
That's the topic of Marilyn Chase's work that you'll be reading the Barbara
replug.
It was the steam ship that enabled plague to reach the new world for the first
time in the 20th century.
It had limited impact on humans,
but it did establish a sable reservoir of infection among wild rodents and the
southwest of the United States where it persists to this very day and causes and
ongoing trickle of cases of Mubarak plague in this country.
The great disaster was India from 1898 to 1908 when she experienced some 13
million deaths from the bubonic plague.
Now present day plague,
and I think a number of you may have,
the idea that plague is something medieval that doesn't have anything to do with
the modern world,
and I want to make it clear that plague is not extinct.
Indeed.
I have a friend myself who was a survivor of bubonic plague,
which she contracted in Arizona and the southwest,
uh,
as I said,
it continues to cause a trickle of cases every year in the United States because
it persists in the wild animal population
and there are occasional flare ups.
So we also need to remember there's a somber background threat then of Boob onic
plague even today,
which is made more vivid by the threat possibly of bluebonnet plague as an
instrument of bioterror.
And just to show the sort of modern,
here's a modern image of the grim reaper,
uh,
as still with us now,
our focus here in our class will be instead firmly on the second pandemic and
especially its last terrible century in Europe,
the 17th.
But let's talk about some of the features of Boob onic plague and we'll begin
with its etiology.
Again,
a bit of jargon.
And by that I simply mean the causes or origins of the disease.
And the plague is a disease with a complex history of four protagonists.
First there's the bacterium,
um,
and there it is,
uh,
your Sinia pestos sometimes called.
Um,
more in a more old fashioned way.
Pasta relas Pestos it was discovered in Hong Kong by Alexon dairy person,
a Swiss student of Louie poster.
And at the same time by um,
his rival,
the jump in niece,
physician,
she busts a Butoh Kitasato a protege instead of Robert comp.
So the first protagonists is this bacterium.
You're Senate.
Yup.
Pestos and then there are two vectors.
The vector is normally another bit of jargon and animal or insect responsible
for conveying a disease to human beings.
And in this case,
there are two vectors or carriers that conveyed the disease to human beings,
fleas and rodents,
especially routes.
And then there's the fourth protagonist,
uh,
you and me by between 1894 and 1898,
you're a person and his colleague,
Paul Louis C mall,
unraveled the complex relationship among routes,
fleas in humans,
that God and the bacterium that governs the epidemiology of Boob onic plague.
Normally the plague began as an infection,
an epidemic among animals and especially wild rodents,
hamsters,
gerbils,
prairie dogs,
chipmunks,
squirrels in their burrows are underground catastrophes unknown to humans to
place.
A particularly important moment was when it inflicted this particular creature
and friend that lives not so distant from us.
Rothfuss rattus the block route or ship rap.
And as you see a extremely cute,
it is unlike his cousin,
the Brown route that took over.
It's ecological niche later on and it's more familiar in modern times.
The black rap was definitely not shy,
but lived in close proximity to pupil with whom they shared the same dietary
preferences.
So the rock was extremely important.
The bacterium was spread.
Then third major character is the flea,
a highly efficient vector for boob onic plague.
The flea is naturally parasitic on warm blooded animals in a single feed.
It's sucks up an amount of blood equal to its own weight.
I'm talking about something like a billion bacteria at a time and here we're
looking at the slide of a flea and gorged with blood after a meal,
no once infected.
And here you'll feel sorry for the poor flee.
The flea does not survive the plague either.
The bacterium blocks the gut of the flea causing it to starve to death,
poor thing.
But before dying in a frenzy bid to survive the flea feeds repeatedly and in
each bite inoculates perhaps 100,000 bacteria into the bloodstream of its warm
blooded victim.
So when a rodent host of fleas Sikkens and dies,
the fleas leap to the warm body of another mammal that passes within leaping
radius.
And the flea also is capable of hibernating for as much as a couple of months
lying in its weight.
Now how did human beings come to be involved in this catastrophe?
Well,
it might be at some times that the remote steps were wild.
Rodents lived,
had their ecological systems disrupted,
perhaps by floods or droughts that sent animals scurrying over long distances.
And then they encountered other rodents who lived in close proximity to men and
especially our friend,
the black round.
Alternatively,
human beings invaded rodents,
habitats exposing themselves to infection,
soldiers perhaps,
or refugees in times of war or hunters and shepherds.
And so the first photo side that is the first low locus is where infection
sprang up among human beings.
We're the first infected men and women would share their fleas and infection
with other members of their households,
so the plague would then begin not as a disease,
so much of isolated individuals,
but if households,
housing conditions were important,
overcrowding with whole family sleeping in a single bed facilitated the exchange
of fleas and there were particular moments that were especially dangerous such
as the laying out and final attentions to the dead as the body hold the fleas
infesting it became desperate to escape to the next warm body.
That approach quite possibly you and me.
Then there was the wider spread and this was dependent on networks of trade and
commerce.
It was not an accident that plague emerged when it did in European history.
It's spread over land and the long river valleys by river traffic.
Now,
fleas obviously are severely restricted in their range,
but routes are really wonderful travelers.
They hide in the shipments of wheat and are transported over land.
They travel by barge down waterways.
But the garments of victims were all so important because there were recycled
non remember how precious an item of clothing was in the early modern world.
And so the clothing of dead men and women was packed in crates and sold in
markets and fairs,
often with fleas intact among their folds,
certain professions.
We're also highly at risk,
uh,
street vendors,
market stall holders,
washer women,
grave diggers,
physicians,
priests,
and also millers and bakers because of the dietary preferences of your friend,
the black rock.
But the disease also went further a field and it did so by sea.
And shipping was essential to the spread of the plague over a long distance and
helps to explain its epidemiology.
It's tendency and that is to arrive in a country first by striking port cities
and only then moving inland by road and river traffic in factored routes would
clamor aboard ships by ropes and gangplanks where there could be lifted a board
and create some grain or shipments of clothes.
So eastern bull was a great hub of trade in the Middle East and it linked the
rest of the Mediterranean world by trade,
overland across the Balkans and by ship to Venice,
Naples,
Genoa,
Marsay,
Valencia.
Sometimes there was havoc at sea when a whole crew and its passengers would be
killed by the plaque before they arrived at port.
And there were ghost ships that floated on the Mediterranean once reaching a
port.
However,
the ship would dock and routes would disembark in crates or by rope or by the
gang plank again.
And at the same time,
in fact,
it passengers and crew could go ashore together with their fleas.
Normally the first indication of plague,
one that's dramatically apparent in [inaudible] novel the plug.
But we'll also see in some of the paintings,
uh,
that we'll look at a time after next.
An important indication was a sudden and massive die off of routes.
And there would be pictures like this of rots killed by an epidemic of Boob onic
plague,
in this case,
Sydney,
Australia.
So ports are crucial and epidemics and in the development of public health
measures to counter them.
Almost invariably in western Europe,
the plague arrived in port cities and then spread inland following roads and
rivers in the large cities.
The disease typically would arrive in the spring,
reach a peak of ferocity after a few weeks,
then continue as a violent outbreak for two to four months and then decline with
the coming of cold or dry weather either to disappear entirely or to be
rekindled when favorable climatic conditions returned.
Well,
if that's the etiology in a nutshell of the plague,
I'd like to turn now to it's symptomatology in pathology.
That is how does it affect the individual human body
and the study of the symptoms of the epidemics we study isn't just a matter of
ghoulish curiosity.
I'm going to argue that the history of each epidemic disease is distinct.
That's one of the reasons that I will be showing slides to fix the image of a
particular disease in your mind because it's important not to confuse them
because each has its own history.
Under crucial variable is the differing way in which each of these diseases
effected its victims.
And a feature of the plague I would argue is that it seemed almost purposefully
designed to maximize terror.
I will be showing you some vivid material and I'm sorry that it's just before
lunch and indeed a couple of years ago in this class,
someone in the front row fainted,
um,
with some of the pictures.
So if you don't wish to look at them,
I can tell you in advance.
Ah,
it's not compulsory.
You can simply close your eyes and then he case you're Sinia.
Pestos is exceptionally,
very lint because of its ability to overwhelm the immune system of the body
after an infective bite.
There's an incubation period usually of one to six days.
And then the classic symptoms appear.
Yeah,
the for beginning launching the first stage of a bionic plague.
And that is at the site of the flea bite.
There's what's called a carbuncle or gangrenous black blister surrounded by red
pockmarks.
And this will be familiar to you because it's been immortalized in the nursery
rhyme.
This is the ring or ring or roses.
Okay.
Know also part along with it,
there's high temperature and shivering,
violent headache,
nausea and vomiting and general flu like symptoms after which the patient passes
on to the second stage of bubonic plague.
Okay.
When it invades the bacteria invade the lymph system and drain into the lymph
nodes a couple of days later,
a so called Bobo,
the which gives the symptom that gives the disease its name,
the Dizzy Boob,
OnDeck plague,
the plague of boobos appears.
This is an infected swelling of the lymph nodes or hard mass,
the size of an orange beneath the skin.
The side of the Buba varies according to the location of the infective bike.
If a fleet bikes,
the legs,
the boobos usually in the groin and um,
would look like that.
If the flea instead were to bite the arms,
the boob ball would appear in the armpit or on the neck.
And um,
there would be symptoms that would look like this or like that.
In any case,
uh,
Daniel Defoe imagined and he writes in our book,
but the agony was so violent from the blue ball that victims hurled themselves
from roots or into the Thames to escape it.
And there was a general consensus that the body in all of its excretions urine
swept the breath,
had an overpowering stench.
This led on,
I want us to remember how dehumanizing the symptoms of plague war,
and that's tremendously important to the way that society's experienced it's
outbreak.
In the third stage,
the bacteria release a powerful toxin and this circulates throughout the
bloodstream and it's the toxin that kills it.
Attacks tissues causing blood vessels to hemorrhage and giving rise to propolis
subcutaneous spots.
The so called Tokens of Plagge,
another bit of jargon to remember the plague is associated with tokens and
these,
let's have a look which looked like this.
They gained their name because they were thought by many to be the signs.
That is the tokens of God's anger.
The anger that led him to smite his people with the plug.
Now the talks and initiates the septic phase of this disease causing rapid
degeneration of the muscles of the heart,
of the kidneys,
of the nerves and the central nervous system.
And this leads to such symptoms.
His bloodshot eyes,
general prostration,
fever,
nausea,
severe headache,
and progressive neurological damage that's manifested by slurred speech,
a staggering gate psychic disturbances and arrangement.
Uh,
we again see how this disease is terrifyingly dehumanizing and agonizing,
and it leads then to delirium and coma.
Sometimes it also causes gangrene of the extremities.
Um,
and I will also have a picture of that and this May in fact be the origin of the
term black death.
Now in terms of the symptom ontology,
let me pass on from not to this.
This is a Franciscan friar Michael of Piatsa a corner clear.
You'll remember I said Massino was the first place to be afflicted by bubonic
plague in 1347.
He wrote this terrifying description of how it afflicted as SIF software.
He wrote,
not only did the burn blisters appear,
but they're developed in different parts of the body gland boils and some one
the sexual organs and others.
Oops,
sorry.
There we go.
Um,
and others on the arms or the neck.
At first,
these were the size of a Hazel nut and developed a company by violence.
Shivering fits that soon.
Render those attacked so weak they could no longer stand upright,
but we're forced to lie in their beds,
consumed by violent fever and overcome by great tribulation.
Soon the boils grew to the size of a walnut than a hen's egg and they were
exceedingly painful and irritated.
The body causing it to vomit blood by vitiating the juices,
the blood rose from the effected lungs,
the throat producing on the whole body,
uh,
putrefying and decomposing effect.
The sickness lasted three days on the fourth at the latest.
The patients succumbed.
So as soon as anyone was seized with headache can shivering.
He knew that he was bound to pass away within the specified time and first
confessed his sins to the priest and then made his will.
So death occurred and about half of cases within a few days though some of the
afflicted lingered in agony for as long as three to four weeks and then a
minority slowly recovered.
So the symptoms of Gubernick leg are agonizing.
They're terrifying,
dehumanizing as sufferers succumb to elusive nations and delirium.
Now there are three forms of bubonic plague and I want to mention what those are
immediately.
These are not three separate diseases.
They're one disease in three separate manifestations.
The first is what we've been describing as classic bubonic plague,
the most common and historically most important form.
Then there's septicemic plague,
which is an overwhelming infection in which the patient frequently design dies
even for before developing the Boopa.
But this is I said is not a separate disease,
simply a foreman that form of plague and it's most common among the older
elderly
and then there's pneumonic plague,
which again is the same disease,
but clinically and epidemia logically distinct.
It begins with an ordinary case of plague,
complicated by pneumonia,
and can then give rise to a secondary catastrophe within the general disaster.
That is the disease is then spread by bacteria,
coughed out in the sputum of the victim and spread person to person when inhaled
by those near him or her.
Now this form of flag is not dependent on fleas.
It's highly infections and as far as it's known is 100% fatal.
And even today in the antibiotic era,
there's no cure for pneumonic.
Plague and pneumonic.
Plague is also recorded in your off true in your favorite nursery rhyme.
This is the orange shoe,
Archie,
you,
we all fall down.
Now what would the doctors do?
What were treatments historically,
there was a continuity of from the black death through the 18th century based on
galenic principles of dealing with the disequilibrium of the humors.
So the main indication of treatment was to assist the body and expelling what
was called the pecant humor responsible or the more biphasic poison the
physician regarded.
His task is one of assisting nature as the body was already clearly attempting
to expel the poison.
After all,
it was vomiting.
There was diarrhea and sweating.
So physicians attempted to assist the body in its fight,
perhaps directly by bleeding,
a very popular therapy.
Although there were intense debates about timing,
about the best veins to be opened and the amount of blood to be drawn.
Other key practices,
we're administering powerful purgatives or medics so the poison could pour forth
more copiously or to cause the patient to sweat piling him or her high with
clothes,
even mattresses.
So the poison would pass out through the pores and forbidding the sufferer to
drink.
And of course,
Lansing or cauterizing,
the Boob oh itself,
so that it too could discharge it's load of poison directly.
Some doctors applied hot compresses.
There were also internal medicines that were administered as they were thought
to raise the boobos or to hasten recovery by four to find what was called the
flagging animal energy of the victim.
Uh,
things like brandy or opium.
But in practice,
treatment was pitifully rare for plague sufferers.
Physicians,
priests,
and attendance recognize that they were powerless,
that they were too few in number to cope with the catastrophe that engulf them.
And they perish to in great numbers during the outbreaks and many overcome with
carer,
like everyone else simply fled.
So one of the terrorists of the plague was that it broke the common bonds of
humanity and the common plight of plague victims was often to be abandoned to
face agony and death alone.
Let's listen to the famous,
an awful testimony of Boccaccio in the Decameron,
um,
describing Florence,
me,
sorry for momentary technological glitch,
but we'll get there.
Here we are.
Uh,
this is book concho describing and 1348 let us admit that one citizen fled after
another and one neighbor had not any care of another parent's snore kindred ever
visiting them,
but otherly they were forsaken on all sides.
This tribulation pierced into the hearts of men and with such a dreadful terror
that one brother four soca nother,
the uncle,
the nephew,
the sister of the brother and the wife,
the husband,
nay a matter much greater and almost incredible fathers and mothers fled from
their own children even as they know,
as if they know way I pertain to them in regard to where of it could not be
otherwise.
But that it countless multitude of men and women fell sick,
finding no charity among their friends except a very few and subject to the
avarice of servants.
So this is our first overview of [inaudible] and its three pandemics.
Next time what I'd like to do is to talk about the response of communities to
this catastrophe and to look in particular at public health measures designed to
protect communities.
So that's where we're heading next.